alors
on a voulu nous faire croire que c'était
une main d'un cétacé comme une baleine
ou un dauphin parce qu'évidemment vu
l'ampleur des phalanges ça ne peut pas
être une main humaine mais ça ce sont
des esprits rationnels évidemment que
c'est une main d'Alien qui est arrivé là
sur cette plage au Brésil et qui a dû
traverser traverser l'Atlantique
peut-être que cette alien s'est posée en
France et qu'il a été jusqu'au Brésil
mais c'est une découverte fondamentale
et la NASA en juin a lancé une enquête
aux États-Unis sur tous les témoignages
d'ovnis tout ce qui se passe on va tous
avoir évidemment que c'est un alien et
la vérité va éclater que même les aliens
ne peuvent pas te guérir
un extraterrestre ou un truc chelou chez
lui je sais Castaldi oui on le sait moi
j'ai déjà vu la Dame Blanche d'accord
j'ai vu
la Dame Blanche encore
non mais si je vous promets non mais
c'est un truc vraiment qui m'a
traumatisé pendant des années au bord
d'une route j'étais au bord d'une route
j'étais en voiture avec ma cousine on
s'est toute les deux Mia crier on a
accéléré et c'est quand même bizarre de
la colle et dangereux pour la santé
à l'époque alors
[Rires]
que je me sois trompé là pour le coup je
vous promets on l'a vu oui
une dame quoi c'était comme une espèce
de silhouette un peu inquiétante et qui
est au bord d'une route normalement il y
a des sangliers blancs
elle faisait rien de spécial elle était
comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
du côté de Dijon il y a un virage très
dangereux qui est mortel et des dizaines
de personnes ont vu la Dame Blanche
Versine de ralentir parce que ça a été
dangereux mais c'est une bonne parce que
moi c'est pas une vanne
suppose que ils ont presque
ce fantôme cette dame elle a déjà vu
quelque chose
qui viennent c'est Fatou qui dit par toi
tout simplement c'est pas des voix elle
est juste dans la paille à sa cote et
puis voilà non c'est quoi de de
personnes de mon enfance ou des gens qui
parlent avec ma voix et je suis persuadé
que ces gens qui parlent avec ma voix
qui me racontent des gens des gens quoi
des gens qui parlent avec ta voix
et qui me raconte ma vie alors que je ne
les ai pas connus
oui tranquille Fatou est au Sénégal avec
Jean-Pierre
ils me disent des choses ils me disent
par exemple ce qui va se passer demain
ou après-demain et je suis persuadé que
ce sont des esprits extraterrestres qui
savent que je suis ouvert à toute
communication qui viennent vers moi
c'est Gilles qui a un pet au casque qui
entend des voix ça n'a rien à voir avec
les cheveux d'accord avec toi moi je
crois que la science et la raison
des vrais bruits vraiment des bruits
ouais des bruits
dans une maison et j'entendais des
bruits de bottes vous savez des bref des
grosses bruits de bœuf
des gens qui marchent des bruits de
bottes et j'ai pensé
pas loin et je me suis je me suis
renseigné en fait la maison dans
laquelle j'étais en fait à brûlé et
cette maison appartenait à l'inventeur
de la godasse monsieur godasse les
bottes sur la tête de la Mamère et en
fait je pense que nous on a pas rien que
Mokhtar c'est quoi on entend
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive en tournée le réceptionniste il
est là c'est une vieille abbaye très
vieille qui a été prolongée en 9 tu vois
et qui est devenu un hôtel et on me
propose la chambre une chambre rouge
avec du drapé rouge et tout est comme ça
moi j'étais épuisé pourtant et je
commence à m'endormir et je sens que que
me dit que tu restes pas là tu vois et
j'allume j'allume la lumière je regarde
un peu partout je dis bon normalement ça
va quoi il y a Berg je suis épuisé je
repique
j'ai éteint la lumière cache je dis
dégage alors je sens il est pas François
Cluzet
c'est comme si on me disait ça je n'ai
pas entendu vraiment ces mots là mais il
y avait une prime qu'un il y avait une
présence qui me disait tu ne dors pas là
tu vois c'est chez moi là tu vois et je
la troisième fois j'appelle le mec qui
qui m'accompagne mon petit Pierre Lebert
que je salue j'ai dit il y a quelqu'un
dans ma chambre j'ai changé on va aller
à la réception vers la réception le mec
une banane comme ça me dit j'étais sûr
que vous allez revenir
parce que tous les gens qui dorment là
tous ceux qui sont un peu réceptifs
disent il y a quelqu'un et le cette
personne est morte donc assassinée genre
dans cette chambre et l'âme de cette de
cette personne elle est restée là et moi
ma gueule lui revenait pas il voulait
pas que je dorme là pas le Stade de
France
comme à Loire quoi t'as pas suivi non
non non non non
non
si on vous dit par exemple cette chambre
faut pas y aller parce qu'il risque
la chambre de Jean-Marie vous allez
dormir avec mon odeur la personne
moi je suis sûr et certain que je ne
pouvais pas en m'interdisait de dormir
là et j'étais pourtant épuisé Delphine
j'avais acheté une ancienne maison et
dès que j'allais dans dans différentes
chambres à chaque fois acheter une
ancienne maison oui ça paye bien
non et en fait à chaque fois que
j'allais dans ces différentes chambres
j'avais toujours l'impression qu'il y a
quelqu'un derrière moi du coup j'ai fait
venir un quelqu'un qui qui fait partir
les esprits effectivement quand il est
venu il a dit ça lui faisait la chair de
poule et il y avait plusieurs personnes
dans la maison plusieurs hommes donc il
est venu il les a fait mais il y avait
eu un massacre dans cette maison toi
c'est juste qu'il y a eu du passage de
la vie quoi
du coup il les a fait partir et mais moi
je ressens les choses
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi de vous déranger oui moi je
me suis fait doubler en voiture par un
alien une fois sur l'autoroute pas loin
de Rennes ils ont des gros moteurs il
était dans une clio II il avait une
grosse tête d'ampoule des Ray-Ban on a
eu un œil contact et il a pris la fuite
par peur que je le démarre pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible et après elle était
nettoyée
avec de l'ensemble de la sauge des des
trucs comme ça de la sauce et je vois
pas j'entends pas en revanche je ressens
les choses et quand je perds quelque
chose je demande aux gens qui
m'entourent de m'aider à le retrouver
dans la minute je retrouve les choses
donc si vous perdez quelque chose vous
pouvez me demander parce que j'ai plein
de gens avec moi qui m'aide à retrouver
les choses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est important
tu fais toi par contre il va falloir
qu'on parle à la fin de l'émission
et à vous en particulier alors moi déjà
alors du genre vous allez passer des
conseils de Gilles quand même c'est un
conseil amical
alors à Delphine et Jean-Marie qui ont
été dans des lieux qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas et à tous les
téléspectateurs bien entendu quand on
arrive quelque part maison de vacances
hôtel et à fortiori quand on achète
faire pipi sur tout le tour de la maison
alors non pas faire pipi c'est ce que je
fais moi ça c'est très bien déjà bravo
mais il faut surtout acheter
un [ __ ] pareil non mais sans déconner
non mais le mec je lui dis NON je suis
en train de pisser tout sauf dans la
merde
quoi que vous fassiez hein il faut
surtout acheter des œufs frais aller au
4 croisements autour de la maison c'est
très vrai ce que je vous donne ce sont
des sorciers qui m'ont donné ce conseil
et ça marche il faut aller jeter des
œufs le soir à la tombée de la nuit non
en arrière en arrière comme ça on jette
les œufs aux quatre coins des
croisements proches de la maison et
votre maison sera protégée ça ne vous
arrivera plus jamais d'accord il y en a
bouffer mais tu es tranquille
le mec qui demande pourquoi vous jetez
des œufs
il y a pas de il y a pas d'esprit ici le
dit bah oui je viens de jeter des œufs
jamais rien arrivé moi rien moi j'ai pas
d'histoire
bébé moi j'ai une amie qui avait chaque
fois qu'elle éteignait le salon qu'elle
se lit dans sa chambre la salle à manger
elle entendait des bruits comme si
c'était une salle de balle et donc en
fait elle entendait vous savez les les
Verts qui trinquent un fond de musique
et quand elle se levée
quand elle se levait pour aller allumer
la lumière du salle du salon et bien
tout c'était il y avait plus de bruit il
y avait plus rien et elle se disait non
mais je deviens folle et quand elle
repartait dans sa chambre à nouveau et
moi je suis venu un soir chez elle et
effectivement j'ai entendu et on s'est
levé toutes les deux pour aller voir et
il y avait vraiment rien et les gens ils
Fabien deviné de venir nous faire chier
alors il y a Nathalie Marquay qui
m'écrit ma chérie qui me dit moi j'ai
plein de messages incroyables que j'ai
même filmé pour montrer que je suis pas
folle là tu viendras nous les montrer
quand tu veux ma Nath on embrasse très
fort